you
so the title of today's talk is making
useful materials I controlling structure
and properties of soft matter so I'm
going to describe two exactly what's up
man threads and what sort of our
structures are interested in and soft
matter of concern to me include polymers
gels and surfactants okay those terms
are not mutually exclusive I'll describe
in more detail exactly what they are and
what instances are that are particularly
interesting for us okay so just by the
way of introduction i am from trinidad
and tobago raise your hand if you know
engine and additive a great excellent
fantastic and so Trinidad is known for
many things heats the I think some of
which will probably be familiar to this
audience tonight is certainly known for
Carnival so Trinitite is a small island
off the northeast coast of venezuela in
fact the distance between trinidad and
venezuela the closest point of approach
is about seven miles so we're not very
far from google chávez venezuela
although culturally trinidad and
venezuela quite different venezuela is
spanish-speaking whereas we are
english-speaking that of course is a
consequence only a part of history so
true today was originally a Spanish
colony but most recently was a British
colony before achieving independence
about fifty years ago in 1962 ok so our
population is pretty small 1.3 million
but we're not tiny I like I like to
describe ourselves it's been small ok so
we're certainly not with carnival how
many people are there Fred about
trinidad Congo whew you should
definitely look it up on youtube and
then you can about this inning and we
definitely known for sprinters some of
like to wear crazy toggles like this is
our two bowling and we have a couple of
others work pretty well especially for
their feeds at the Olympics but Trinidad
is also pretty well known especially in
New England if you care about energy
Trinidad is a largest shipper natural
gas with the by natural gas to New
England okay so when it's a winter in
the dead of winter and you're really
really cool if your house runs on
natural gas there's a good chance that
some of it probably originates it in
Trinidad and so we have a fairly active
petrochemical industry we produce oil
and gas which is not so surprising
because we are just off the coast of
Venezuela and as you guys know that as
well as uses a ton of oil and gas we
also produce oil and gas and we don't
just produce oil and gas but we use that
gas often times to downstream industries
so the gas is the source of energy for
us for your rare production ethanol
production as well as steel production
so we're a fairly small country and we
care about things are a cultural and
sports inc we also care about things
that are industrial so many of my
classmates in trinidad where i studied
through high school we're interested in
chemical engineering in many of them
went to study chemical engineering
because they were interested in getting
into the energy sector as it turns out i
warmed up in a chemical engineering
department although i didn't initially
study chemical engineering so I went to
secondary school in Trinidad in for
spain which is the capital light there
and then I left Trinidad come to the
United States men I did an undergraduate
degree material science or 1l many years
ago and I enjoyed it and so I thought ok
well that's what about useful i guess
and i went to grad this column i did
also my degree in material science it's
like either polymer physics or polymer
science and i enjoyed that if you like
research so I just kept on doing it and
I'm
and it's still fun so all the way from
as long as it's fun and as long as they
keep me employed okay so today what I'm
going to talk to you at night about
actually is a little bit about the
composition of matter ok so I'm
discussing soft matter or soft materials
and that's really a little bit of a
nebulous term rates a little bit of a
ill-defined thing what is a soft
material well as you'll see in a few
more slides soft materials are literally
soft right physically they are softer
than other materials that we would
consider to be traditional materials
like metals for example or ceramics
which referred to as hard materials a
lot of our unifying materials or
classified materials depends on what is
the length scale that you're looking at
or what is the length scale that
determines property of your material
okay so these are all things that many
of many of you in the audience are
familiar with in one way or another
certainly a sand castle we're all
familiar with and a grain of sand the
size of a grain of sand is probably
something like one millimeter so you can
probably have about twenty five grains
of sand in 1h right and so this is
probably what I would call macroscopic
length scales and down here at the
atomic length scales the size of an atom
is measured in angstroms so one angstrom
is one-tenth of a nanometer and one
nanometer is about 11 hundred thousand
the width of a human hair in so here's
the diameter of a human hair right here
it's about 250 microns okay so you go
down by a factor of 1,000 and you're
here looking at the length scale of
transistors right the elements that make
up the function of our about mutant CPUs
in our computers and cell phones and
whatnot I built up transistors and these
guys have a length scale and on the
order of the
okay so lots of interesting stuff
happens in the world red blood cells
here which one through our body are
about 10 microns in diameter lots of
interesting stuff happens in nature and
how we parse or understand the structure
of materials the properties of materials
very much depends on what next here we
are looking at right so for example
these chairs have a particular shape
which might be meaningful to us if we
want to sit down on them but if we want
you to understand something about the
strength of the material of the wood
itself when I'm going to look at the
shape of the chair as an azimuth that's
a full object I'm going to look at the
molecular structure of the wood ok so
length scales matter ok energy scales
also matter and there's a lot of jargon
on this on this slide or I'll explain
exactly what I mean so we all know for
example that it's a certain amount of
energy contained in a slice of bread or
in the food that we eat so for example
the energy content per slice your
friends about 50 calories or 200
kilojoules another unit of energy ok and
we also know a lot about Lea the energy
content or power overcame we measure the
power of cars in horsepower right which
can also be related to the amount of
energy that they are producing for a
unit time ok so when we again look at
materials just as when we consider that
the function of material it depends on
the length scale that we're looking at
when we consider the properties of
materials we also care about the energy
levels while the scale of the energetic
interactions between components of that
material so when you sit on a chair the
energetic interaction between you and
the chair is largely your weight but
when you eat a slice of bread the
energetic interaction by complicated
quite different but the energy that's
released from bad is this scale of
energy whereas when you sit on a chair
you release a larger amount of energy
because you allow yourself to draw and
gravity working century on your house ok
so what I'd like to say is jenky scales
matter in other words the size of your
matter or material that you're looking
at that's it the energy the magnitude of
energy that's involved also matters ok
another fancy words cohesive energy
density I promise you this is all going
somewhere the mechanical and dynamical
properties of materials are controlled
by their cohesive energy density what
does that mean well if you take you know
if you take some jailbreak Apple like
you guys are saying the outside and you
try to rip it apart the amount of force
that you need to exert you know what
it's a tear it apart depends on how
cohesive it is as a material how
cohesive it is depends on what the
objects are that constitute the
materials atoms molecules particles and
the energetic interaction between those
objects okay so if I ask a bunch of you
guys to string yourselves together and
to all hands and I came along and I cut
down to end of that string of people the
strength of that string of people is
determined by the number of people and
how strong each of us holding hands with
each other right so the strength with
with your hands is sort of like your
energy scale and the length scale is the
size of the individual person okay so
this is a very simple way of considering
the behavior of materials dominated by
length scales the size of the object
that constitutes the material and the
energy scale how strong is the
interaction between those elementary
components of material and finally of
course dynamical properties which we
don't normally think up so much in
everyday life meaning how materials move
the speed at which atoms move around
those things are determined by
the magnitude of energetic interactions
between components and the size of the
components okay so why do we care about
this why is he going on at like about
this it's offensive energy density
represents basically the number of
objects you have and the energetic
interaction between objects okay well I
had to give you that definition and that
lead in material because this is exactly
how we define soft matter it's a very
sort of amorphous difficult to pin down
class of materials except when you start
to examine the length scales that are
relevant in determining the properties
of the material energy scales and also
the time scale meaning how apart the
constituent pieces of the material room
okay so soft matter is just a convenient
term the matter that is neither atomic
and crystalline and solid you're a
simple liquid in other words it's not
like water you will all watch yourself
matter however you had some other stuff
in water like some polymer chains or
some particles Martin's very small
models in that mixture of what with
other components starts to see other
properties that mean that needed to be
classified the soft matter okay so
basically the behavior of soft matter is
dominated by length scales sizes of
objects that are neither atomic so not
talking about patterns interacting with
each other and it's not not despotic so
we're not talking about grains of sand
or large models oftentimes talking about
things that are maybe the size of human
hair maybe I'm going two times smaller
okay energy scales in those materials
are also go to the thermal either it's
not necessarily going to need a lot but
what it means is that the constituents
are in motion soft matter compasses
things like gels for example you guys
are playing
jobs outside the components of that gel
always in motion they move on length
scales that are microscopic you can see
them very easily okay and finally the
time scales the ski on which the speed
with which the constituent matter moves
can be quite long in other words the
materials are quite slow bye by
comparison that simple liquids like say
important the molecules in Waterloo move
out very very fast but the molecules in
a gel without much more slowly okay so
soft matter what constitutes is not
matter it's defined in century by the
size of the objects their interaction
with each other and how fast then okay
what are examples of soft matter well
soft matter is a field was more or less
founded for it's age by vision won a
Nobel Prize in 1991 and physics for his
seminal work on liquid crystals but the
thing that's so great about salt matter
and working in this field is that soft
matter is Eddie everywhere countless
forms gels creams suspensions polymers
Inc food a lot of food is actually soft
matter contains and Cheerios that we
work on in the lab proteins and solution
components of your body all make-up soft
matter ok just everywhere around us for
example in foods if you are accustomed
to eating things are just a little bit
gelatinous for example the channel
itself that's considered soft
to shaving cream hope you know many of
you here shape as yet but if you do
shave or if you're familiar with shaving
cream that's considered soft matter or a
complex fluid toothpaste it certainly
considered soft matter it has a lot of
small particles inside of it but the end
it behaves in a way that that we
classify it as being soft matter
likewise ink it's a complex fluid and
polymers these terms are not mutually
exclusive because there are lots of
comments in shaving cream there are
particles in toothpaste sometimes the
particles are made out of all of us okay
who here knows what horror is anybody
you want so order a few people seem to
know not your hand if my definition
agrees with yours a polymer in essence
is a long molecule that is made up of
smaller molecules all attached to each
other okay so installed off essentially
with one beam on a string and that's
called monomer a single pot 1 over and
when you link them all together they
become polymer many parts essentially
okay so all of us are very simple
chain-like molecules that are composed
of much smaller [ __ ] but when you look
at the properties of polymers in
suspension or in solution they're quite
interesting and this is the subject of
today's talk okay what else do we care
about within soft matter we care about
different types of crystals so I
explained to you before that what
constitutes soft man's have really
depends on what length scale you're
looking at how strong magnifying glass
you're using to look at your material ok
because polymers themselves are
enforcing hot surface ok but if we look
on the length scale of the polymer chain
then the material is a soft material
because I like spirited large compared
to the atomic length scale in that same
sense we can have different types of
crystals many of you are probably
familiar with salt for example
atomic crystal you have sodium and
chlorine atoms that are actually
existing as ions that attacks together
in a regular way and deform crystal
there are other forms of crystals
however if you take each of these sodium
and chlorine pattern the highest and
instead of them being our terms there
are actually particles like marbles or
like oranges that you see start in the
grocery store those are also crystals
except the length scale of the
constituent matter the size of the
object is the size of the model or the
orange but it's still a crystal because
it's organized in a periodic and regular
fashion okay likewise you can have
objects for liquid crystals that many of
you are probably familiar with because
they form the basis of the technology in
lots of your lots of your devices
laptops let's talk displays some cell
phones many samples now holdings of new
technology but liquid crystals are very
very well known for their role in
display technology okay so what I'd like
to tell you about is our work we work in
my lab that concerns soft matter soft
materials and as I described before soft
materials are literally physically soft
and that that mechanical nature is due
to the length scale the size of the
objects that constitute the matter
interactions between them and the way
how fast they move so in my lab we study
overall structure and dynamics of soft
materials so we care about organization
of the material or the atomic or
molecular or even loyal organization of
material and we care about hard material
school so we work in three main areas in
the first we use scattering means
x-rays to study the structure of soft
materials and we work very hard to
control the structural south materials
and to make devices and useful things
out of that in the second area we work
on rheology or dynamics of things like
gel polymers in solution right and we
also do some point in my clothes away so
some of the work that we do is is very
very fundamental but the applications
are quite needed if everybody recognizes
what this is it's a car it's a very cool
part and it's meeting a lot of exhaust
so one project in my lab concerns soft
matter that is made up of suspensions of
soot particles this is carbon black
right sort of stuff that you a key at
the bottom of a pot if you're using it
for a long time just as glad deposit
it's just soaked that same material is
produced by the engine of your car when
you drive because you burn fuel as you
burn fuel if the combustion is not very
efficient it generates of particles and
those of particles get in train they get
taken up by the oil of your engine the
soot particles like to stick to each
other and if they stick to each other
eventually that causes problems to the
operation of your engines so there's
work in my lab that considers how to
disperse these carbon black or slip
particles and prevent aggregation of the
particles at each other okay so some of
the work that we do shows up in its
advanced life by simple tests here in
study the biology of suspensions of
these soot particles in oil literally be
taking these you know soot particles
take a teaspoonful dump it into a bunch
of oil stir it all together
a substance and I'm going to put that
between the plates of an instrument and
if you look at how it flows between the
plates okay and based on how it flows we
can get information about how strong is
an energetic interaction between those
foot particles that's important to make
these dratted water boils okay what do
we see well we see things that look like
this sometimes just to give you a little
video some interesting morphologies we
can have the suspension of carbon black
particles are all dispersed in an oil
and depending on how we treat those
particles we see these interesting
structures that form when the carbon
black particles are subjected to flow
okay so we start with the homogeneous
very uniform dispersion of these
particles in oil and then you make the
the suspension flow we subjected to flow
and the suspension form structures in
response to that hill so these are so
some of the things that we study in my
lab to try to improve the performance of
everyday materials such as in generate
other work in my lab and really the
topic of today's discussion is focused
on controlling the structure of order
soft materials and the materials of
interest for us our block copolymers or
define what those are my topic
surfactants I'll describe what those are
government as well as nanowire
suspension okay and there are a lot of
challenges to be overcome there are lot
of potential benefits to be gained in
using in controlling the structure of
these materials to make new devices I'll
describe how we solve a problem that
will head into that works ok so we study
a lot the self-assembly of the patterns
ok some of you guys are playing with
surfactants outside earlier on how many
of you guys did the experiments will saw
the demonstration where you have
pepper powder on the surface of water
and then you touch the surface of the
water with a little bit of a teacher
needs a few people for it ok so more
than a few toys so the stuff inside of
that dish washing liquid can take the
dishwashing liquid itself contains
surfactants surfactants are detergents
they help us the clean things up because
they're thought they can force of
molecules that have two different parts
one part of the law of you likes to be
in water the other part of the molecule
likes to be in grease or oil so if you
have dirty hands although the oil and
water don't mix right so if you had me
greasy hands and you try to wash your
hands using only water it doesn't do a
very good job right so we used two
patterns to improve the efficiency of
that washing process because the greasy
part the greasy dirt that's on your hand
there's a part of the surfactant that
likes like weeds so it associates with
that grease but then there's another
part of this is the factor that likes of
water so the surfactant in essence grabs
on take parts of the Demi's and carries
it off in the water that's how
detergents work ok so these molecules
are called and pathetic meaning they
have two natures they like water they
also like peace and that enables them to
bundle up fleets and carry it away and
what service you can also be the inverse
they can bundle up water and carry it
away in Greece so they're really really
useful molecule if you take the factors
and you look at that at concentrations
that are much higher than he typically
used for washing for washing dishes and
washing clothes what you see is that as
you increase the concentration of the
surfactant you go from having just the
factors that are hanging around in the
water to having something that is a
structure
fluid ok so these surfactants like to
associate with each other and they form
structures that are called micelles
essentially small spherical objects in
which one part of the molecule is
sticking on the outside and the other
part of the molecule is on the inside
and those guys are really small typical
size of these spherical objects is
something like you know one to ten
nanometers so extremely small more than
10,000 times smaller than the width of
the column here ok they've all these
interesting structures as you continue
to increase the concentration that's a
factor in the solution you go from
having these circular structures to
having these were light structures and
then having these sheets like structures
ok so basically this is what we call
self-assembly the surfactants associate
with each other and they all structures
in the liquid my lab works on making use
outdoor structures so clock the polymers
another class of matter so you guys said
it your flavors what all of us are a
block apollyon is formed by a connection
of one polymer chain to another polymer
chain ok so if you take a polymer chain
on the chain is just a snake-like and
spaghetti like object a very long object
that's composed of individual molecules
or linked to one another if you take one
polymer and you connect it to a second
polymer you have what we call a block
copolymer ok they're just two polymers I
don't intend to each other these two
polymer chains if they are of
sufficiently different chemistry just
like oil and water they try to avoid
each other ok so these materials also
undergoes self-assembly and they form
structures that are very similar to the
structures that I should
okay in essence they will form
structures that look like this if you
take a died block copolymer that has two
polymer gloss one attached to another it
forms structures that look like this and
if you take a triblock copolymer on a
attach the part will be attached to
policy you form similar structures but
they can be a lot more complex okay
really really complex actually
structures and these are all owned by
what we call self-assembly you need all
you have to do is eat up the material
and cool it down and you get these
wonderful structures in front of you
well they're great structures and every
they're really interesting in a variety
of instances for example we imagine that
we can use them for making membranes we
imagine we can use them for making solar
cells but there's a big problem right
actually one of the uses of local
partners that is most prevalent nowadays
many of you probably have you know
probably about 100 grams or more with
the block copolymer on you if you're
wearing running shoes the source of your
running shoes are likely to force of a
partner okay so block copolymers are
used to form what we call thermoplastic
elastomers the funny name so complicated
name it just means it's a rubber it's an
elastomer its elastic okay and its
thermal plastic which means that it can
be made to flow by the application of
heat use it so thermal heat plastic
Khloe so these are rubbers that can flow
when you eat them okay so block all is
one of the major uses or block
copolymers attack is to make rubbers
that are used
running shoes so you all have come into
contact about the polymers in some form
or another well here's a little funny
story so when I was in when I was an
undergrad many many years ago my advisor
at the time I was doing a senior project
he said hey you know block copolymers
upgrade you should really you should
really do this project and I thought
okay I need to do as a senior project
I'm going to sign up and I guess in your
project and then when I got to grad
school my advisor there was also working
with local partners you know was very
emphatic and he said really local
followed us out great but a lot of
emphasis on the world's great right and
I thought yeah I mean I think these are
really cool materials they form all
these wonderful structures and I can
imagine that an idea is probably they're
going to be block with polymers on the
space station block copolymers as
anti-reflective coatings on your
sunglasses local partners in your hard
drive block copolymers everywhere right
because they self assemble and they form
these really cool structures and for
sure they're going to be adopted
everywhere well unfortunately they have
not been and up until now the major used
to these wonderful self assemble
materials is the making running shoes
and roofing compounds which are really
important things but they're not the
things that I thought that they would be
used for when I was a student right
because you have these wonderfully
complex structures and a form by these
really interesting materials you can
control the chemistry you can change the
function of the material but a big
problem with these materials is in fact
that they don't organize in a in a
single fashion by themselves okay so
it's just like taking a bunch of people
or a bunch of two-phase if you throw
them down on the surface all the
toothpicks are going to have different
orientations right one is going to be
pointing this way a 120 point not they
want that way just because you put them
down on a surface and you haven't
imposed any definition of the direction
in which they should
point right and if you wanted to make
some use out of a collection of
toothpicks on a service one of the
reason you might make use of that
collection of toothpicks is if you
control the orientation of the alignment
of those materials okay so basically
every bit of computing that we do if you
have a watch if you have a calculator
you have an iphone if you have a laptop
desktop with EGR your television
probably even your blender all of the
computing that takes place in those
devices relies on the ability to control
orientation or the alignment some
material in particular the material is
silicon okay so silicon is an extremely
important element material our modern
world it is the foundation all of the
microelectronics industry and all of the
computing that we do and all of the
ipods and all the items etc that we all
love enough to play with basically would
not exist they would not function if we
did not have the ability to control the
alignment or the orientation of silicon
ok so it's extremely important that when
you work with materials if you want to
get really good function out of the
materials you need to be able to control
the structure and the orientation or the
alignment of the structure and this is
what we knew in my lap ok so all of you
have probably done an experiment what
many of you probably done an experiment
looks like this I'm guessing where you
grow a crystal salt picture of hands how
many people have done it or not about
the experiment that's it so you've all
done this many of you have done this if
you want to have the crystal of soil you
take a solution of salt you get a cup of
water you throw a bunch of salt into it
you mix it up he's on the salt ok and
then you come along with another a piece
of solid swords swords crystal and you
suspend it on a thread into in
ocean of salt you've just made and you
wait and after a certain amount of time
you see that the soul of crystal uses
that you suspended into the solution
starts to grow and it assumes a very
particular shape right what you're doing
in this experiment which is very simple
you can do this at home or in your
classroom what you're doing in this
experiment is your growing single
crystals of salt that's exactly what
people do for silicon in order to make
computers work so folks can do it for
silicon you can do it the salt why can't
we do it for soft material if we can do
the same thing with soft materials if we
can control their alignment we can
address all types of applications right
so basically what we need to be able to
do with soft materials like surfactants
that I discussed before like block
copolymers that I defined before it's
the control the alignment of the
structures that these materials for when
they undergo self-assembly and they form
some really fascinating structures even
if we take just the very simplest
examples of these structures if you take
a structure where you have these
cylindrical domains essentially like
very very small pipes okay if you have
the ability to align these very small
pipes in a thin film over a large area
you can address a variety of exciting
applications so basically what you're
doing is you're making something that
looks like a membrane imagine you have a
sheet of paper and you punched holes in
that sheet of paper and then the holes
in that sheet of paper or something like
one in 1,000 or 110 thousand of the with
human-hair extremely small holes and
those bowls were continuous with the top
of the paper to the bottom of the paper
you can use that for filtration right if
you had a solution or some sign or
something else you can filter and remove
the sand from the water using those very
small holes not only could you remove
the sand from water you can also remove
red blood cells proteins viruses you can
control the way in which different
species passed on the top of that
systems and wanted the system where the
top and bottom are separated by this
memory that's what we work on in my life
we take Oliver's block copolymers that
undergoes self-assembly and form these
cylindrical structures and we force the
structures to all orient align in one
direction it's very hard to do it what
were able to do it and if you can do
that you can make membranes you can make
a raise of nanomaterials like nanowires
or nanotubes and you can address a
variety of applications that are
meaningful for you and I our everyday
life for example we can make membranes
or desalination so these are membranes
for the removal of salt from water so
imagine if you live in a place like
guitar or Saudi Arabia how many people
know where guitarist what about Saudi
Arabia what about Iran what about Israel
so all of these countries care deeply
about desalination technology okay
because water is scarce in their part of
the world and so one of the one of the
principal means by which they make water
to drink is to remove salt from seawater
in order to remove salt from seawater
you need a membrane that has very very
tiny balls the walls are so tiny that
basically the water can get through but
the sword cannot okay so if you're able
to make these align materials that are
talking about you can make
high-performance membranes for
desalination maybe drinking water and
you can address problems in a number of
number of countries another possible
world where fresh water scarcity is this
also you can make membranes for lithium
ion batteries the same lithium ion
batteries that go into myself forward in
your life on your laptop okay because in
that case you need membranes that
control the transport of lithium the
lithium that is an idiom ion batteries
and you can also make solar cells
photovoltaic devices and your views or
rely on in some way probably will come
to rely on more ways in the future for
generating clean energy okay so these
are all things that you'll be enabled if
you get a line soft NASA ok well how do
we do it in my lab we use magnetic
fields we came up with the idea of using
magnetic fields to control the alignment
of these polymers and citizens ok so
hope you guys have played with magnets
and magnetic fields before so many of
you guys probably recognize this little
setup right if you take a battery and
have some wire and you form a coil with
that wire then you can form a magnet
basically using the right hand rule
right so if I have wires that are
running with this and I take my right
hand and I use my
figures to describe the direction of the
that coil of wire then my thumb
describes the direction of the magnetic
field right so you can make an
electromagnet using a battery many of
you probably have and if you put an iron
nail through the center of that finding
then you can concentrate that field and
you can pick up paper clips and you can
play all sorts of games right and you're
also probably familiar with magnets in
the context of composites right how many
of you guys have ever using offers okay
it didn't look like this what did it
look like this so these are both these
are both compasses right that they
operate on different principle so this
is an iphone running a compass
application ok so this uses GPS
satellites to tell you where you are and
what direction you are you pointing but
in all the times before your time when
if you are not the ending they used to
use simple magnetic compasses and the
way that a magnetic compass works is you
take a needle basically a stick that's
magnetic ok and earth has its own
magnetic field so in the same way as you
can control you can use this
electromagnet to play with little metal
objects if you take a magnetic needle
and you just suspended in air it will
respond to the direction of the Earth's
magnetic field and the needle will point
to the geographic North Pole ok so
that's how opposites work so basically
you can use magnets to control the
alignment of magnetic materials like a
needle in a pompous Earth's magnetic
field is something like 0.5 cows cows is
a unit is used to describe the magnetic
industry
just another example if you take a
little bar magnet and you take some iron
filings and you sprinkle iron filings
around ormaybe it if you do it very
carefully you can get a map of the field
lines of that either okay and so you can
see many of you probably seen drawings
field lines of magnets and if you do
this experiment with metal filings you
can do it at home or you can program it
allows your classroom you can see how
magnets affect the distribution of these
iron filings ok so my vet appeals can
line up metal filings along their
feelin's so what we asked is can be used
a magnetic view to align soft materials
and the answer is yes you can you can do
it but the field strength that you need
is incredibly large almost a million
times stronger than the magnetic field
of Earth and we used to drive compass ok
so in my lab we use a technique called
x-ray scattering we should x-rays into a
material and we look at how the x-ray
scattering off material and that gives
us information about the structure of
the material what we do is we take this
very large magnet and we install it in
the flight in the path these x-rays so
we should x-rays into our samples the
samples are held under a very high view
and then we look at how the x-rays
scatter off our samples ok and the way
in which x-rays scatter off the sample
tells us something about the structure
of the material so we can see the great
deal of precision exactly how the field
affects the alignment of the material ok
and so I'll discuss a couple of results
for example this is an image this steel
bar is 100 nanometers so this image is
with something for the transmission
electron microscope it's like an optical
microscope but instead of using light
you're using electrons to do your image
okay so you can see objects are very
very very small and what we see here is
that the structure of this polymer it's
a block copolymer like epic I before
it's nicely aligned by the application
of that magnetic field and the field is
something like a hundred thousand to a
million times stronger and Earth's
magnetic field so these are really
really strong beetles okay so what can
we do if we align soft materials I gave
you a story and we could make membranes
that we can pay portable kids and in
fact we can and we work with some of
these areas the remaining five minutes
or so i'll just mention some of those
applications so lithium ion batteries
are all around us to my phone oftentimes
I have my phone in my pocket I happen
you know my pocket up Cara point my
pocket here my pocket here the lithium
ion batteries are not as safe as we
would like them to be okay so from time
to time you the years as we hear stories
about lithium ion batteries excluding
laptops catching on fire or hybrid
electric vehicles completely going up in
flames because there's a problem with
the lithium-ion batteries if they're
really good night reason sense that they
deliver a lot of power and all reliable
back in our devices but you need a very
special material to sit between the
electrodes of that battery in sort of
positive terminal and the negative
terminal of that battery are separated
by a very special material that material
is essentially a membrane that controls
lithium ions flowing good battery
if that membrane fails what you get is
this sort of very dangerous situation so
what we're working on in my lab is using
these soft materials this is a block
copolymer as I discussed before and what
we have the ability to do is to make
membranes where to self-assemble
structure of the block copolymer that I
discussed before is supporting the
transport of lithium ions for that
battery okay and it's just like if you
take a bunch of spaghetti that's all
jumbled up versus a bunch of spaghetti
that's all straight and this is before
you cook it if you want to look at which
arrangement is actually better for say
passing some water through that
arrangement you would want to have the
system where you have that spaghetti
straight right if you had a noodle and I
was straight versus the noodle that was
all curved around and you wanted to flow
something very quickly through that
noodle you would want the noodle that's
straight because it supports a higher
amount flux of material going through it
and that's exactly what we do so we take
magnetically will be allowing these
structures of the block copolymer so
that we can have higher performing
membrane for use in batteries for
example okay so these are the things
that we make to make all the films where
we can control lithium ions passing from
one side to another side for battery
applications second and I think maybe
this may be the final example is in the
alignment of nanomaterials to making
solar cells okay and it's a very
complicated chart what it describes is
efficiency of solar cells over the past
35 years
and what you can see is that these
different colors correspond to different
technologies and there is a very steady
increase or improvement solar cell
efficiency over time which is good if
you want to generate clean energy at low
cost we want to have the highest
possible efficiency solar cells we can
have one way to do that is to go from
this current situation and we used to
making solar cells from harmless to a
situation that looks like this so
instead of having this random mixture of
materials what we really want is a
mixture of materials where the materials
are equally spaced and there are aligned
inside of the device so it's another
area where if you control the indictment
of materials you can enhance the
properties of your device that's what we
do in my lab making devices that look
like this solar cells may be aligned
nano materials and the final example
looking at membranes for desalination
here we use carbon nanotubes and I
describe this really wrong this is a
depiction of a carbon nanotube if you
have a Smalling of tune you can allow
water molecules pass through the tube
that you can preclude you can prevent
the passage of salt the salt ions are
actually larger than water molecules
when they are in water okay so what we
do in my group is to make membranes
polymer films where we take carbon
nanotubes we put them in a mixture with
surfactants the same surfactants will be
talked about before we align that
surfactant system using a magnetic field
and then we deliver rise the material
using light and at the end of this
hoping it is a polymer film that has
carbon nanotubes these very small pipes
that have been a line by
view this allows us to address
applications in desalination or membrane
separation okay so I'd like to summarize
and what you should focus on this summer
is a little bit technical but we should
focus on this first line in the second
line you can control the structure of
salt in cereals you can control the
alignment or self-assemble structures
and soft materials if you use my data
fields if they are largely to use a very
very strong magnetic field you can make
polymers and surfactants align along the
field and you can make useful materials
from them and so what we do in my lab is
to try to take that ability of magnetic
fields to align materials to make
devices are useful in our everyday life
for example desalination membranes solar
cells or membranes 499 lat okay thank
you very much your attention